we're at the Roxy's point
trash I don't know I know Beyond trash
like I mean we lost 20 in a row we was
trying to lose on purpose thank you yeah
we started stunning Justin pay yeah we
started meeting that's how I started
learning was I knew like me
David nawaba Jay Sean Tate
Justin Patton
somebody else
I'm like bro who the [__] can I win a
game with this [__] yeah nah like I
always thought of Jalen green Kevin
Porter hey job like yo don't get
adjusted to this losing [__] it's not a
league is yeah but at the same time I
had to tell them like this [__] y'all
getting away with over here you go to
any other teams you be out to lead he
wouldn't play you're not playing I
wouldn't play no facts so I'm trying to
explain that to them because they think
it's sweet